en este vídeo vamos a analizar con mayor
detalle nuestro conocimiento o
comprensión de la factorización la
factorización es algo que hemos venido
haciendo desde hace años pueden regresar
y ver cuando comenzamos a pensar cómo
factorizar el número 12 bueno puedo
escribir el número 12 como 3 por 4
también lo puedo escribir como 2 por 6
todos estos son factores válidos o puedo
realizar una factorización prima de 12
puedo tratar de escribirlo como el
producto de lo que podemos considerar
sus constituyentes básicos que son los
números primos hemos hecho cosas como
que 12 puede expresarse como 2 por 6 2
es primo pero 6 no puede expresarse como
2 por 3 por lo que 12 puede expresarse
como dos por dos por tres como lo vemos
acá este es solo un repaso esta es una
factorización en primos y vimos un
análogo que aprendimos por primera vez
en álgebra 1 lo que aprendimos en
álgebra 1 o quizá en mate 1 o entre
álgebra fueron cosas como cómo
factorizar cosas como x
6x y quizás se den cuenta de que podemos
escribir x cuadrada como x por x y 6x
como 6 x x ambos tienen a x como factor
por lo que podemos factorizar lo de
manera que nos queda esta expresión x
por x + 6 lo que hicimos fue factorizar
o sacar estas x que estoy señalando en
azul por lo general esta idea de
factorización si pensamos en números
escribimos un número como el producto de
otros números y si pensamos en
expresiones escribimos una expresión
como el producto de otras expresiones
ahora que estamos avanzando en álgebra
vamos a pensar en realizar esto pero con
expresiones de orden mayor lo hemos
hecho con una equis o una equis cuadrada
pero ahora pensaremos en qué pasa si
hacemos esto con algo a la tercera oa la
cuarta a la décima o a la centésima
potencia pero es realmente la misma idea
podemos comenzar con mono mios que es
una palabra sofisticada para referirnos
a algo de un solo término digamos que
tenemos 6 x
a la séptima potencia cuáles son las
diferentes formas con las que puedo
factorizar esto pausa en el vídeo y
piensen en ello puedo expresar esto como
el producto de otras dos cosas bueno
puedo reescribir esto como igual a 2x a
la tercera porque veamos para tener 6
tengo que multiplicar este dos por tres
y porque tengo que multiplicar x a la
tercera para tener x a la séptima
potencia pues x x a la cuarta noten que
dos por tres
es 6 y que x a la tercera por x a la
cuarta es x a la séptima se suman los
exponentes al multiplicar cosas con la
misma base pero esta no es la única
forma de factorizar lo como vimos aquí 3
por 4 no era la única forma de
factorizar este 12 también podemos
expresar esto quizá igual a x a la sexta
porque podemos comenzar a multiplicar
por 6 y luego tenemos que multiplicar
por otra x por lo que podemos escribir
esto como x a la 6 x 6 x es frecuente
que haya varias formas
actualizar un mono mío de grado mayor
como este y también existe un análogo
aquí de la factorización en primos en el
que realmente tratamos de descomponer o
reescribir esta expresión como un
producto de sus componentes más simples
como lo harían para 6x a la séptima
bueno pueden reescribir esto como 6x a
la séptima igual a pensamos primero en
el 6 sabemos que la factorización en
primos de 6 es 2 x 3 y luego x a la
séptima son 7 x multiplicadas entre sí x
x x x x x x x x cuántos van van 5 este
seis y este es 7 algunos de nosotros lo
que hacemos al decir 2 x a la tercera es
tomar este 2 y luego x por x por x y
porque tenemos que multiplicarlo pues lo
multiplicamos por 3 y luego x x a la
cuarta y como veremos el poder pensar en
los monos de esta manera va a ser útil
para factorizar cosas con mayor grado
que no sean mono mios
que son binomios trinomios o polinomios
en general esto lo haremos en futuros
vídeos